and kwang hun kim the lefty gets the
start for the cardinals and he has been
rolling and he gets the start on his
birthday dan happy birthday to kk 33
years old
test him again
drifting out towards right center and
just enough room harrison bader on the
track
[Applause]
and now rizzo strikes out the first of
the night for kk and this will be a
lineup that features dylan carlson at
the very top
carlson one-nothing cardinals wow
he jumped on it
dylan carlson home run number nine and
what a series he has had
he said something about the fans getting
into it a good atmosphere certainly the
case here fastball middle in belt high
and dylan carlson does not miss this
thing
the one over
drilled in the air left field hanging up
pat back and johnson makes the catch
got him to swing and miss struck him out
the side step high leg kick kim's pitch
a swing and a foul tip into yachty smith
strike three the 2-2 pitch
swaying and a miss and he struck him out
three strikeouts already for kim 3-2
and it's a walk the second walk
issued to the cardinals tonight
we're runner goes throw down a second
tag wow
holy cow
i mean stop it javi
2-2
on the ground to short sosa bobbles and
nico
is safe at first
swinging a miss
strikeout number four
[Applause]
come back and this could be two out
there oh yeah it's a double play
[Applause]
hits it off the end of the bet they had
a shift on and this may drop and it will
dylan carlson
now thinking two on his way to second
and in there almost thinking three as
three defenders converged on the
baseball nola narnado send one to the
track first time up the 1-1
moronato with a drive into left center
will then go
gone
nolan oronato two-run homer
three-nothing st louis
dan as if you were ready to predict the
future talking about the home runs the
issues and this time nolan aronado does
not miss the barrel
wisdom will take his base with two outs
and a man aboard back down to taylor
that one lace back up the middle first
hit of the game
for the cubs baez stings that one at
108.5
two outs two on jake mariznick has some
power wisdom at second buy is at first
that's drilled to right center and that
one's gonna touch down that'll be extra
basis in to score his wisdom
on his heels marisnick into second and
cubs within a run it's 3-2
jake mariznick
oh what a play nolan aronado
takes an extra base hit away from nico
horner down at the hot corner
swinging a miss and a strikeout number
six
the 2-2
and carlson
slices one in the gap left-center that
ball is down
thinking two again on his way to second
standing up
he's got a home run and a pair of
doubles tonight
the one-two goldschmidt swings
and misses strike three
and also avoids any further trouble
the 2-2 to rizzo
high fly ball
right center
vader back with room
how about kk tonight another strikeout
and that is seven for kim
and that one is in there got him
how's the light deals on three and two
and molina takes inside a 91 mile an
hour fastball close enough to be called
a strike but that's ball four
swing and a miss al zalai pumped up and
he pitches around the walk
off the end of the bat
shallow left o'neal sliding catch in
left field
he probably thought that ball was
hammered it was off the end of the bat
so a little bit of a tardy jump but
makes up for it
with the speed and the budweiser play of
the game
and that's a rocket back up the middle
ortega with a two out single
and his first knock of the night
shallow center
coming on vader
got it
what a catch harrison bader
oh my goodness
an incredible catch vader racing into
shallow center
and takes the hit away
wow
here's dylan maples down 21st appearance
there's a slider for a strike got him
oh no contreras quickly waving out the
medical team of the cardinals shows up
hit on the head it's good to see this
him walking under his own power here is
this fastball from dylan maples just
pops out i mean that catches him about
as clean as you're going to get hit in
the helmet
and sosa is going to stay in the ball
game
[Applause]
off the plate and he walked him so a
strikeout of bader jose hit by the pitch
on the helmet and a walk to carpenter
and the right-hander on for the 38th
time a 2-7-6
era
there he goes
and the bases are loaded for nolan
[Applause]
arenado the air right center maristic
has a beat on it got it
and winkler gets out of the jam
big out right there cardinals leave them
loaded
takes the walk
and now we'll see if
they run for him
hayward
jumping out of the dugout on the third
base side and he will run for bryant the
one pitch
it is double play
and mundo sosa on a tough hop turns to
the 2-2 pitch
swaying at a miss he struck him out
the cardinals three outs away from
taking three of four against the chicago
cubs
alex reyes is brad detailed
a few moments ago had the first blown
save
of his career had been perfect two bowls
two strikes
rizzo into the shift
sosa
one out
the one-two pitch
he got him
two outs
three-one pitch
and the time run is aboard as reyes
stares back into the home plate umpire
manny gonzalez buys it first and an o2
pitch
reyes to mariznick sway and a miss got
him
bounces back cards win three of four
they win this one three to two and
they're a game above the 500 mark